[Music]
[Music]
absolutely
what a lad now not many people had a
crazier 2020 than today's guest from
having no contract
and looking for a job to making his
international debut for scotland in
about the space of six months
one of the best career turnarounds you
will ever hear
as well as being an international and an
english premiership star
he is also one of the great lads who
throughout his career has never been shy
of a diesel so we may get some good
stories in this one
it is of course the laird himself
scott steele welcome staley
cheers mate what an introduction um
great to be on
loving the podcast um bit nervous if i'm
honest but uh
no it'll be all good um but now i'm
really excited to be on and thanks for
having me
absolute pleasure to get a lad like you
on here and you've just been named in
the scottish
squad for the summer tour how good is
that yeah me amazing
um obviously was involved in the the
autumn and the six nations stuff
and then since coming back i've had a
bit of injury issues so i've not played
that much but um
great to be involved in that and
hopefully get back playing soon for
harlequins and then
kick on into that which is exciting so
you're not fed at the moment
uh so this is going to be my first week
back um
i had a hernia that happened back in
november
and then just sort of battle through
with it and it was it was all right at
the start and then just got lost and
lost and got to stage where
went and saw the surgeon he said yeah we
need to get this done so
had that about five weeks ago been
training for the last
maybe two weeks so i'm modified just
doing bits and bobs and then um
yeah hopefully hopefully in the mix this
weekend for for harlequins we play
sale on the friday coming up so yeah
fingers crossed them in the mix and
it'll be good to get back out there
you must have obviously made a huge
impression on the scot scotland coaches
while you're in the squad up there to
still be getting picked without even
playing
yeah good uh i think it's more that
alley prices went on the line so
there's not many other options about
right we have to pick them so we'll get
them back in
um but now there's there's a few there's
a guy joe john he's played he's played a
fair bit
and then there's another guy that's
uncapped actually at scrum half so
um pick quite a young exciting squad i
think there's 17 guys or so that are
uncapped
so um we go out to play romania and
georgia so
good opportunity to sort of play these
these younger lads and
and see see what they're all about but
uh for me personally now i'm really
excited to obviously have another
opportunity to
try and pick up some more caps so you
were named as a halfback
yeah i was a bit bit disappointed they
didn't just put me as utility
uh after my couple of cameos during the
six nations but
um you know me jimmy i love the the sort
of physical side of the game so
my opportunity to play back row against
ireland was
uh scary but also it was a dream come
true for me
that you could play absolutely anywhere
you're one of those guys so good
you're so good over the ball i know that
was my dream or just in that island game
we had quite a lot of the ball and if
anything i was disappointed that i
didn't get a chance to try and get a few
jackals but
um no hajj was just happy i made it
through you know
all good and didn't have to go off
injured and playing for scotland
unbelievable what
what a journey but anyway we better
start at the start before we get too far
into it because
that has been some journey for you so
let's let's take the listeners back to
the start
life growing up in scotland what was it
like
good um really good actually um
real sort of sporty family um
dad played a lot of rugby growing up and
and was always involved in the local
rugby club at dumfries
i've got two older brothers that play um
so playing with them in the garden stuff
like that from from day one was
was what it was all about and then yeah
i grew up playing there with
a bunch of really close mates that still
speak to now and
just your classic sort of local rugby
club real family sort of rugby club and
um grew up playing there and grew up
played there until i was about 17 and
stuff like that and um
that was really good um yeah southwest
scotland dumfries
pretty small town not not much to do so
um
yeah i loved getting stuck into football
and rugby
so um now can't kind of any complaints
on that front
was it always rugby or did you play a
bit of football because i remember you
being a bit of a wizard
playing a little bit of football before
games
training irish i would say game respects
game jimmy but
you were one of the funniest people to
watch playing football and then warm-ups
um i could tell that you didn't play
that much growing up that's all i'm
gonna say
um i actually did oh that's even worse
what happened seeing it
you i was a ganon new zealand
different level different style of play
maybe i've got to yeah
that's doing that now i definitely lost
my confidence
oh you guys were all good real good
yeah london ish we're probably better at
football and more at rugby which is
probably
how it went too much time playing
football and train not actually doing
rugby stuff
um no i played a lot of football growing
up played at school
um went to coleman which is like
sort of top top tier scotland at like
sort of 13 to like 16. um
top to your scotland football doesn't
say that much but at the time it was a
big deal
um and then yeah i played for a fair bit
and
played in a really good school team we
won a sort of national competition a few
times and
got to stage where it was football or
rugby and
there was a lot of traveling back in the
day up to up to come on like three times
a week
um missing out on sort of uh social side
of things with mates and stuff like that
and then
i just yeah decided that i had to knock
the football in the hair i was playing
rugby on a saturday and then traveling
up the road to play to play football on
the sunday
um it was just getting a bit too much so
i decided to go with rugby
um like i said for the more that social
side getting to actually spend more time
with my mates and
hanging around after games and and
having a good time so it was really that
that sort of
made me do it um i thought no regrets i
loved it
no doubt uh you had a changing room uh
clubhouse it was a great place to be
after games like any good rugby club so
um i think that was the thing that
swayed me um
but yeah love love playing football
still watch
a lot of football and enjoy it but i'm
pretty pretty happy with the decision
i've made how it's all turned out
yeah fair enough look at you now and so
then
once you made that decision to play
rugby i guess then
your next step was somehow making your
way into the leicester tigers academy
how did that all come about
um was pretty random to be fair so i
played like the age group stuff
like scotland 17's 18's and and we we
played against england he had a lot of
lesser guys playing with them and
we had a leicester guy in our team and
excel
through like he's his granddad or
something could play for scotland so he
played
playing the scotland team and we beat
them for the first time in
a lot of years or whatever so um he just
got in contact with me saying that
there's like a shortage of scrum ass at
leicester
academy and that they needed a nine and
um so he basically said just get in
touch with the coaches here's an email
address so i just sent an email address
um an email across um
i was like didn't really know what to
say just like give me a shot
like whatever so my mother dad sat down
and we're like
right okay i've sent this email and they
were like yeah well come down for like a
two week trial and it was like all right
sweets went down two weeks and it was
like
the most intense training i've ever done
like at that stage leicester was
pretty old school and they really tested
your sort of character all that kind of
stuff and
uh went down for two weeks and then like
yeah um we're going to give you an
academy contract for for the year um
like basically
still relying on mom and dad and stuff
like that it was absolute pennies
um but in that year they they had a
crisis it's come off injury-wise i think
like ben youngs went away with england
second choice got injured third choice
got banned
for like six weeks and then it was just
their fourth choice and they had no one
else so i was there
and ended up playing in the premiership
when i was at 18 and played like
off the bench like three or four times
and i was going this is unreal this is a
professional rugby straight in
class and then so after that i signed a
two-year like senior sort of contract
thinking this is gonna be amazing more
the same like crack on and then
no one got injured played about three
games in two years
and was all alone yeah at loft broad
national one and i was going right this
is probably
actually how it goes for young guys i i
just got extremely lucky
um to play in them few games and not
have a howler so they so they bought me
but after
yeah two years there that was more the
sort of reality of
senior rugby moving into a team at the
time that was like winning premierships
and stuff so
first year great two years after that
not so great just
sitting around holding a bag and and
basically just
being a professional rugby player but
not actually playing any rugby which was
tough
so that must have been um intimidating
going into that leicester starting are
you restarting a little bit at least the
playing site nah
benchmade well ben don't get carried
away
but yeah it was intimidating because
they they had a lot of big names at the
time they're
like so like i said ben young's like
toby flored castro giovanni
and scott hamilton like all these sort
of craig newbie all these sort of like
big dogs that had played uh
international and
and all over the place and to come into
that it was a bit you know rabbit in the
headlight sort of thing and there's a
scrum off obviously you're trying to
organize people tell them what to do but
as an 18 year old just sitting there
going
i'm not really confident nothing myself
never mind to tell him what
he's got to do etc so it was a bit yeah
chucked in the deep end
but um i think for my for my career
going forward at that stage it was
it was a good way to do it and it was
intimidating place in general at least
at that time it was quite um quite tough
quite abrasive if you needed to
if you're a young lad it was just get
your head down get on with your work
um if you felt like saying something in
a meeting
you got told not to search you've been
told to shut up pretty sharpish so
um it taught me a lot of lessons that
way especially if you
you're going to move club and you want
to get your head down and all that kind
of stuff um
i sort of learned that from early on but
um now it was good it was good
experience
i think we we're not winning the lv cup
that year and i was on the bench for
that
and didn't get on but um
celebrating like we won the world cup
basically it was loving life
and and celebrating as if i basically
single-handedly want us to turn them in
but in reality i'd done very little um
but now they were all amazing
experiences like i said um
but yeah probably it probably was a bit
tough at the time but it definitely
helped me for from moving forward yeah
what was the initiation for
leicester tigers back then um pretty
brutal to be fair so
you had to get down the uh
front of the bus on an away trip or
whatever um
i know how we had the paddle thing at
london ash when people would like you
take your top off people would slap your
back after a song
there was no song it was just you had to
try and touch the back of the bus
and guys weren't slapping you they were
basically battering you
so you would just run down the bottom
and guys would be like
on the back of the seats like kicking
you throwing punches and it was more of
a
popularity contest so if you were liked
by the guys you would
you would get off pretty lightly if
you're a young lad
you were getting it regardless and i
think there's only a few lads in the
history of that actually made it to the
back of the watch and
touched it so you basically ran until
you got basically
beaten up enough that it was that was it
you were done and you go and sit back
down
so you'd like be excited to make your
debut
so yeah it was pretty tough but like i
said if a feud came
in and guys weren't really lying to you
and uh
you had you know if you fancied yourself
a bit or whatever then you were getting
a tough tough time
but you kept your head down you were all
right uh you sort of got
got away with it a bit a bit more but
yeah it was pretty scary
that's just the last that was the
leicester wave that was just the less
the way and that's how they said it was
done and they were winning stuff so it
was all good but
looking back now i don't you'd be
getting away with that
yeah at least the irish you got to you
got a chance to get out of it by saying
a great song but
that way you got you're just stuck
no chance just just pure violence yeah
just pure violence
all right so you moved down to irish
that was was that pretty much to
chase game time obviously you had been
sitting on the bench or holding the
backpacks for a long time
um leicester those next sort of three
years so was that
did that sort of inspire the move down
to london irish
yeah uh 100 just basically got to stage
where i was like well i could do this
for another couple of years or whatever
but
um it was that or take a chance move
somewhere and try and play
um at the time i remember speaking to
them and they were like are you gonna
move to
london irish like bottom the table sort
of team and all that kind of stuff where
you can stay here and win stuff and i
was like
i'm not gonna be the one winning stuff
i'll be the one holding the
holding pod or running the water i was
like that's not really accelerating
yeah exactly pretending to be a
professional player basically
um so it was yeah it was a move to try
and try and get some more game time and
like any sort of like coach will tell
you the best way to get better is by
playing
um so yeah that was that was a move and
a few guys that had moved to irish the
year before me from leicester
uh johnny harris of prop jimmy stevens
at hooker and alex lewinton
obviously and guys that you'll know so
and they moved the year before and they
were in the same boat as me they were
not playing or they were on loan to
nottingham and
were doing well there but just
regardless we never get a chance so
they moved and ended up playing 20 plus
games for irish and i thought right well
um gives me a bit of hope if they're
able to go there and do that and
actually play and prove that they can
play in the premiership then
might as well might as well go for it
and take that chance so um
yeah that's that's why that's why the
move came about and you did
get that you did get a starting spot
straight away didn't you you impressed
someone
yeah um so yeah there was two two scrum
offs ahead of me that were like pretty
senior and i was definitely
going as a third choice nine um and then
ended up yeah but our first game of the
season was
was against harlequins at the token on
the double header sort of thing and
yeah when when they sort of read out
while that was starting obviously
grafted
crafted hard in pre-season and they were
impressed and they backed me
um yeah but that was a moment when i was
like right well i've definitely made the
right choice here like
if i'd been involved like even on the
bench or
i got told that i might play in the lv
cup in the european games
when i moved um but then to be involved
in the in the first game in the prem was
was unreal
so i went from playing that loughborough
national one
uh in front of you know two men and
their dog
at the sidelines no atmosphere
whatsoever
first game uh irish was in front of 60
000 people at twickenham i was thinking
all right well this is a bit different
so that was that was pretty amazing
um we lost the game but it was pretty
tight and
as fast games go i went all right pretty
solid didn't didn't do anything
um didn't have a howler but didn't
wasn't spectacular in any way but it was
just one of them that sort of settled
the nails and was
able to crack on after that and you kept
your spot throughout that season eh
yeah so um we ended up i think we
finished nine for whatever
which was at that time was all right it
was basically
we didn't want to go down and and we
managed to stay up and win quite a lot
of games towards the end of the season
and
ended up playing i think 20 25 games or
whatever
so um yeah a real good season for me
sort of a real
realization that right well i can i can
sort of play at this level
um and sort of putting them doubts at
the flight that i had before of like
right i'm a good enough or i'm not
getting a game at leicester
is that for a particular reason etc so
um
that was a real good year coach like you
said liked me
great great bunch of lads there the club
that made it easy for me
um and yeah it was just that sort of
like really
sort of uh made that decision like the
right one in that way that i could turn
around after a year and going right
we'll have actually played a fair amount
here so
um yeah it was good but then that coach
left and then a couple of
kiwi coaches came along talk me through
that yeah
uh yeah that was not so good um
so yeah coaches came in uh
well they were all basically something
southern hemisphere coaches came in
um brought a few players across with
them like yourself
big superstars coming across i hadn't
got there by this point i
i was still i was still watching from
afar
hoping that you guys could stay out yeah
yeah that was right you were you were
sitting there nervous watching the games
crying come on stealy
win this one sorry mate i'll let you
down
um yeah so they came across um
and just basically tried to try to play
a quite different style of how we tried
to play and
don't think we had the players or the
sort of squad to be able to do it the
way they wanted to
um and yeah it was a real tough year
um a lot of change like you said at the
club and for me
personally i still still played a fair
bit but um
yeah it was probably pretty dark so
going from
the first year of being this is great
playing every week and we're going
all right and we're pretty solid sort of
thing and the premiership to that year
was
real tough um and yeah it was just quite
quite a tough place to be in coming in
after getting not just beat but
absolutely smashed most weeks was was
pretty tough to
to mentally deal with and often to to go
again
but um yeah just one of one of them
things that didn't really work out
yeah so what would you put that season
down to oth other than the coaches
trying to play a
southern hemisphere style what else sort
of went wrong in that yeah
uh i don't think as a plane group we
really
really bought into it we had quite a lot
of senior guys there that were
played a lot in the premiership for
years and they and they sort of
saw these guys coming in and i was
probably too young to even realize
it was happening at the time but yeah um
there was no real buy-in to what they
were trying to do it was pretty made up
early on that right this is going to
work and
if you've got people on different pages
coaches try to do one thing players
we're not really agreeing with it then
it's never it's never going to work out
well and like i said with
the players that we had in our team it
didn't really suit we wanted to play
with
sort of our big ball carrying back rows
and in the wide channels but the problem
was we weren't really good enough to get
it there half the time so
our best bulk carriers aren't even
picking up carries which
doesn't make sense but you can
understand what they're trying to do and
what they
basically were trying to do is what a
lot of teams over here are doing now
anyway so
i think it was just one of them things
that they didn't really get a good
buy-in there's quite a lot of guys
coming to the end of the career and so
we're thinking well i'm not
i'm not going to change it now sort of
thing this is what for me in the past
and um yeah just a couple of them
factors
and the fact that our squad probably
looking back now wasn't
wasn't good enough to really to do that
or or even if we
played a different game plan it was
always going to be tough to stay up
anyway
so yeah all them factors mixed into one
just
makes for a cocktail of failure
basically
that buying's massive though you need to
get the fire yeah
as a coach you're pretty much stuff from
the get-go yeah it was
it was the way that they sort of came
across and were showing all the
everything that they showed was clips of
of super rugby teams doing stuff and
you've got unbelievable freak athletes
doing stuff and you're just going
great but we don't have that like we
don't have that and
and then like their knowledge of the
league wasn't great so they'd be
we'd be analyzing teams and they'd be
getting guys names completely wrong
about what they're gonna do and stuff
like that
and as a player you're just looking at
going like well they've not even really
put the time in to sort of realize
what's what and all that kind of stuff
so
that'd be another reason that you sort
of guys been buying because of that
but um like i said it was just
there was a pretty settled group of like
senior lads there that
sort of made the mind up early on what
what the deal was with the coaches and
and then it didn't really work out
anyway after that game over yeah
so then talk to me about the year down
in the championship
i thought it was really really enjoyable
yeah obviously going down there you're
thinking oh this is gonna be
this is gonna be tough like no one
really wants to be there
um good opportunity for the young lads
to get a bit more game times probably
positive out of it and
i think the way that the coaches sort of
handled that year was was really good
we had a lot of rotation in the squad so
the guys were playing
basically knew knew what games were
going to play and rest before
you'd even played them so it was good in
that terms like took the pressure off
and
um it was still pretty dark at some
times obviously going away at some
tough places down at cornish pirates and
nottingham away and obviously the
pictures aren't great and
uh yeah weather conditions etc
um don't help so there was tough times
but i think as a squad and there's a
sort of like going from one extreme to
other of like really
down in the dumps the year before week
after week um
you could not even you don't have to
play your best and you still win
and um boys would still be in and good
spirits and stuff like that and
um it was really really enjoyable i
think the coaches
did quite well that year to sort of make
the most of it of
of a bad situation really and you had a
real good rotation going on didn't you
you were two weeks
starting two weeks bench two weeks rest
hey that was
yeah set up for the night yeah it was
great for the night
so yeah we got sat down at the start of
the year and we're told this this is the
way we're going to do it
it doesn't matter don't worry if you
have a bad game because you know you're
going to start the next one or
etc if you're on the bench um so it was
great yeah
three of us really sort of enjoyed that
we all got on so there was no
overlay guys getting annoyed because you
knew the crack regardless so
um that was it was great for us um
um yeah it was a strange one though to
get sat down and told like regardless
you're gonna you're gonna
do that it wasn't something that i've
been used to before or a lot of guys had
um that was quite good you could plan
your weekends when you had a weekend off
you could
go go back home for me go and see my
mate so
have a busy one somewhere etc so um
no it was good it was real good you you
definitely would have made the most of
those weeks off
any good stories you've got from your
times of those weeks off or
or the socials uh
i don't know which years the socials
were but um
they also emerged the one but i remember
one of the best socials we had was with
uh christmas time when we got split up
into different groups in london
and we were in the same group and we
started in richmond did a bit of a pub
crawl whatever
um that was an amazing day and
we were getting off the two-bit ones or
like yeah we're getting off the train at
one stage
and we'd basically bullied jacob atkins
the snake
and we ended up celebrating them around
the pool in the middle of the
of the train when he was just watching
he was like right come on guys it's not
funny now and you get off the train soon
you get off the trains and you just feel
like i'll find your own way out man
find your own way out man it's just all
that sort of
big muscle bulk that he's got match just
slide his way through
facilitate to get off slippery scales
[Music]
sled on his way out and we ended up in
london
in central some place and got to the
stage for a
full day on the session i was i was
pretty steaming and
jeb sinclair the canadian that we all
loved was i
right right young fella getting a cab
you're coming home so
he dropped me off sort of near home
literally 500 yards from my home
um and i've obviously thought at that
stage all the the night's not over yet
right i need to go and see what's
happening so i went a lot
stumbled across uh it was near like
richmond or like london scottish's
ground there was like a um big sort of
stall or whatever of like christmas
trees for sale
yeah so i thought right i'm gonna jump
in here and try and steal a christmas
tree i've not got one yet it's only a
couple of days of christmas it's like
two o'clock in the morning
so i've jumped in there like all over
the place like trying to pick up this
christmas tree and i just remember these
guys come out these
three or four workers like proper dodgy
characters like gypsy looking guys
and i'm just stuck there with a stream
like what are you doing all that
you could barely speak i was just like
so they take me into this cabin and i'm
going off christ this is the end of it
for me
this is you've noticed you've had too
many slip-ups in the past this is the
last straw this is it
they end up phoning the police um please
come
escort me if i'll take me back in the in
the back of the van
home enough i've taken snapchats in the
van
try to be a lad being like this is an
interesting uber
this is a funny looking uber all this
kind of stuff put it on instagram
snapchat story ended up getting home
woke up the next day being like that was
a good night i couldn't really remember
much of it whatever
just go on snapchat i've got loads of
messages coming through like what are
you up to
what's that look at it and i'm just like
oh no
whatever done so get to the club on the
monday
and i'm sketching out i'm like surely no
one knows it should be all right like
not that bad um nothing was actually
done i didn't get any sort of fighting
or any sort of criminal sort of stuff
all right okay i'll be fine
come in get through training the fear
got me through had a really good
training session thought right
that's put everything to bed i'm good
now and then the head coach
nick kennedy just comes up to me and
he's like yeah we had an interesting
phone off a guy that
you know sells christmas tree and he was
just phoning up and he had your name and
said
it was just checking up to make sure you
got home okay i was just like
bastard i was like he's just done that
to tell them that i was there doing what
i was doing
and to be fair he saw on like
me and kendall had a lot of these sort
of conversations but he was like to be
honest if there's one time that you can
sort of
let loose and stuff like that it's a
social but just make sure you take care
of yourself and behave yourself
for the rest of the year so that was my
first first one in that year which uh
didn't really work out well because i
ended up getting in trouble later down
there
but i do remember you getting in trouble
i thought that might have been the end
of that story but
i do remember you having to train before
the team came in and trained after
the team had left so what was that what
have you done that time
so that was well lloyd's stag do
um a great man one of the great
diesel guzzlers as you guys would say
and
we're just staggered over in dublin it
was like the friday saturday
and we come back on the sunday
unbelievable
stag dave's class and uh we got back on
sunday morning
a few guys that came from all over the
uk a few guys from yorkshire carnegie
that
will do from back home and um yeah so in
the morning whatever stay in this hotel
i'm like well we'll have a few drinks in
the morning just to say bye everyone
sort of sort of wrap everything up and
we have a few drinks there then we get
to the plane
me will lloyd said the chavez think
right well
we can have a few more let's let's let's
not let hangover kick in just yet
whatever so we get we get pretty steam
in and then we get back to twickenham
we have a few more drinks and i end up
outside just
passed out basically on the floor um
one of the boys calls me a new boy but
he keeps my phone
so i go home wake up the next morning
just get banging on the doors
louie my housemate at the time saying
like get up mate we've got training
whatever and i got to get up and i am
still properly steaming not like tipsy
i'm all over the place
i tried to get in the shower i'm like
falling over and i'm just like to him i
can't go
training like this there's no chance i
can go to training he's like right okay
like
what you're going to do is i'll phone
the team manager and say that i've
like been ill all night i've hardly
slept whatever
um said that i had diarrhea um
that was the one that i went for i went
to phone him i was like
i don't even have a phone like [ __ ]
going on i was like louie can i borrow
your phone so i phoned
team manager he's not picked up so i've
left a message
um basically saying that i've been up
all night hardly slept like really ill
um and i'm not gonna be able to make it
to training today
so louie goes off to training i'll go
back to bed thinking oh
that should be all right fingers crossed
i'll get away with that
and come back from training and louie's
just like
bad news mate i was like what the like
all the other guys that went to the stag
do
they turned up like they weren't great
at training that but they turned up and
it's not looking good there's a lot of
questions being asked i was like
all right okay this isn't looking good
so
get uh get my phone back off one of the
boys later on and
and get a text right you need to come in
and uh have a meeting
uh with the coach at someone like half
six in the morning i was going gee
pretty early like what's that all about
so got in for half six and the boys were
meant to go and train against bath that
day
um away at bath so they're leaving early
and he just came and he's like look
i ain't buying this and we think you've
had a big weekend
you've either carried on on sunday and
ended up getting
getting drunk again or you've just not
manned up like all the other boys turned
up they were a bit ropey and stuff out
but they turned up into the sessions
just
you know putting the team fast selfish
like proper grilling really made me
feel like [ __ ] and i was like rightly so
um
and i was just sitting there like oh no
like hopefully i can just get to
training like get through the day
and that will be and is that right
you've got a ton up you have to go home
you're not training for the week
it's a written warning and you have to
come up at seven o'clock at night
to do your running it's just going to be
fitness you're in the
the snc guy um robbie palmer he's gonna
turn up by him and do some
do some training and i'll say christ
that's not great whatsoever
so i've went back just feared up the
whole day and then i come up later on at
night to do my running
and you know robbie's a pretty like
funny guy pretty
relaxed and i was thinking right maybe i
could have a bit of chat with him and
he'll sort of understand
he gave me absolutely nothing he was
just like do this do that and i was like
oh how are you like i thought it speak
to you man
i don't want like this isn't like we're
having a good chat and it's all done
everyone's [ __ ] really disappointed
in all that kind of stuff and i was just
sitting there going
jesus like expected it from the head
coach but not from you mate come on give
me
something so good then fitness sessions
and i'd like was smashing it i've never
run so fast in my life fitness wise i
was like the fear just get me through it
came back the next week and it was it
was all good but then
it was still a bit obviously not great i
got told that i was it was one of them
weeks that was meant to start
didn't start um and then
the following week or whatever another
boy tommy bell and ended up
going on going on the steam when he
shouldn't when he was injured and stuff
and turned up the next day and
he got and that he got a grilling from
from the head coach and he had to get up
and apologize in front of everyone
um and the head coach was like i should
i should have made steely step up
and apologize a few weeks ago but um
barely you have to get up and apologize
to everyone and as soon as that happened
i was just like
well up to belly and you shook his hand
i was like thank you and he was like
what was i
thank you for taking all of the heat off
of me
onto you everyone's forgotten about what
i've done a few weeks ago
it's all about you thank you and he was
like
he's like as if you didn't have to
apologize i was like mate stop living in
the past mate you really need to pick up
your attitude
it's not good enough so yeah
i own a lot for that really distracting
everyone from what i've done
so the following week so i thought i was
i was out of it and then
uh brendan venter came back and now he
used to come in for like
a week or so and that's when i was like
right hopefully
hopefully he's not really heard about
that or whatever and then there was an
injury or whatever
so i end up starting against yorkshire
carnegie in the away game
it was like our biggest game of that
year because they were the team that was
like most likely to challenge us or who
would meet in the final
and uh brain inventors going around the
team like the guys that are getting this
chance to start in this game it's our
biggest game this is our
our first choice team you know when
we're not rotating for this one all this
kind of stuff and he's going around
saying
um guys are unlucky to miss out miss out
and he just points at me he goes like
you
are unbelievably lucky to be starting
this game you don't know how lucky you
are
after what's happened and all that kind
of stuff and i was just there going
jesus like
no pressure whatever biggest game over
here and he's putting over somewhere we
played that game it's like a big game of
the year it was on tv and stuff and i
played pretty well i just remember after
that he came up to me and he just said
well done that was it nothing more and i
was like that's that's a good result
that's that needs to pass the test i was
like thank god for that
so it was after that that i decided
right i can't have any more of them so
i just have to stay in line and battle
down and make sure it was all good until
until we got promoted so you were all
good from there on in
yeah i think it was it was all done
after that there was no
no further things um but yeah i was just
basically
in terms of going out and stuff i think
i stopped drinking actually for
three or four months i was like right
you can't afford to do it
and you need to really show them that
you're actually making sure you're being
a good professional and stuff so i
stopped drinking for
three or four months and then it got to
the final or whatever and then drank
then so
um yeah probably wasn't the wisest thing
because you go from no drinking
whatsoever to like three or four days on
the steam so
after a couple of pints i'm already all
over the place i was like
the logic was good the theory was good
but in reality
probably not the smartest thing but um
yeah it was all good it was all good fun
so obviously didn't fit any further
contracts because you had another couple
of years here or
had you already signed by this point no
no so
yeah i went into negotiations after that
and signed for a couple of couple of
years after
so and it's all good i loved it um i
knew
the situation we were in and um had a
few chats with teams back home
um being scottish and stuff for the
glasgow and edinburgh guys
are always looking for scottish
qualified players and stuff and
they did a few chats with me but i loved
it irish i loved
living in london um good bunch of boys
and i knew if
i played well in that team i could play
in the premiership weekend week out
which is obviously
a decent standard and yeah it was i
didn't really think about it i just
thought yeah i want to be here so
signed on for a couple of couple more
years so how was your year up in the
premiership
after the promotion yeah that was it was
it was tough but it was a bet it was a
much better year than the year before
when we got relegated
um i think the coaches they were young
coaching group they came
basically straight up from the academy
coaching set up into the
into the first team when we were in the
championship and then they
they obviously took us up into into the
prem and
i think the environment around the place
was much better than it had been the
previous years
um even though we were getting beat most
weeks like
there's a lot that was a lot closer than
it was before we
picked up so many losing bonus points
and games and
so many games were ahead and we looked
back and we've thrown it away in the
last five minutes or so
um but as a team and as a squad i think
it was more
everyone's giving everything here and
doing a bit but we're just
falling a bit short or um just
not really closing out games and not
being smart whereas
the year before there was a bit more of
a feeling of obviously the whole coaches
and
there's a few guys that were probably at
the end of their career and
weren't really caring that much so i
just um
sitting there picking up picking up
their money and not really fussed how it
went sort of results-wise but that year
even though we got relegated it was it
was a different feeling to what it was
before and
i sort of felt for the coaches because
they got like chucked in the deep end
there
um and to get relegated
in the fashion that we did i think i
remember at the time it was like no one
had picked up as many losing bonus
points
in the season um and like we did that
yeah so
showed that we weren't a million miles
off but um
ultimately yeah yeah it was relegation
again and then them coaching
coaching group sort of sort of filtered
out um
and that was that was a shame like being
a club i was there for
six years and i had like six different
head coaches
one would come in one would go out and
every time as a player you're thinking
right please
i need to prove to the next coach that
i'm a decent player or whatever
like i hope i get picked and i think if
anything it was it was a good thing for
me to do that because otherwise i could
get quite complacent and and be like
right well
i know that i'm roughly going to play in
games you know i'm going to be
there around the squad that i'm going to
be involved um
but with that knowing that a coach would
go at the end of the year i was like
right
i've got to really try and like hit the
ground running with preseason and stuff
like that and
yeah so it definitely kept you on your
toes a bit not knowing who was going to
come in and
what players they were going to bring in
etc so um
but i did feel for that coaching group
yeah and how was it following year in
the championship
um that was not not so good for me
personally so the coaches had came
new coaching group had came in and it
was like the first time that i've been
left out the squad for the first couple
of weeks and
there was no chat of rotation or
anything like that the year before that
we're in and
um it got to a stage where i
walked my way into the team onto the
bench and
um yeah we were winning games and
it was a different format so we didn't
have to worry about the playoffs it was
just whoever when
whoever finishes talk goes up so
like the year before if it had been the
case i think we would have gone up with
like a couple of games to spare at least
like three or four or something like
that but
um yeah so that that year for me
personally was not great like the team
was winning but
we could tell like for our squad
compared to other teams like our
our budget and our sort of like caliber
of players compared to them
uh that year was like a bit of a bit of
a joke we had a lot of internationals
playing but
we weren't we weren't really playing the
way we should have we were winning games
and
sort of brushing over the issues by
saying all we've won so
like we could have lost it could be
worse um whereas
in the past obviously in the
championship before it was we were just
like right we're going to try and
set our standard to be as a premiership
team as what we want to be regardless if
we win
uh by 40 points or if we win by two
points if if we do well and we play well
the way we want to play then
we'll judge it off of that so um yeah
that year was a bit tougher for me i
ended up playing
towards the end oh well like halfway
through the season and stuff like that
and
managed to pick up my that stage was
like my 100th game
against like cornish pirates at home and
that was another moment where i was like
well
ideally i'd want that to be in the
premiership and playing in a
yeah and a big game against someone to
do it cornish pirates at the
the mad stad in front of about 400
people
wasn't great but at the same time it was
an achievement all of a sudden i was
proud to play that many times and
mom and dad came down and we won and i
played well so
yeah that that was decent but um we went
up in the end
um but there was definitely a feeling of
like right if we carry on playing like
that then
it's we're not going to last long in the
sort of premiership sort of thing so
um yeah that year wasn't um
it was it was it was all right that's
how we described it just all right we
weren't as good as we could have been
and for me personally i did
ended up playing a little bit but
nowhere near as much as i've played for
the
previous years interesting and then the
big year 2020 hit
and you get let go by the cut by london
irish how did that happen and
did you get a reason and why you will
let go
um so i wasn't i was sort of in and out
of the team
um started being like started
at this um start the season was playing
we had a ninja few injuries and then um
a few guys came in after um the world
cup stuff
and the competition got got a lot more
intense and
i was playing the odd game here and
there but something new at the time i
was like
this isn't looking great for me um maybe
it's
maybe it's time to move on but at the
same time i was having
quite a lot of conversations with the
coaches and they were saying whenever
you've played you played really well and
all this kind of stuff and we want to
sit down and chat about next year and
getting something sorted so that
conversation
dragged on and there was a lot of guys
in the same boat getting told yet we'll
we'll get something sorted and
it'd be like right you'll find out at
the end of end of february
um and then it was into march and then
the guys are going like we
want to get it sorted now sort of thing
what's the way and it was
um sort of mid-march that i sort of went
in and had a chat with
the head coach and he just said look um
really really sorry like but there's no
there's no space in the salary cap like
i've tried to
juggle a few things around and stuff
like that over the last couple of months
but ultimately there's
there's no there's no contract for you
here next year and i was going like geez
like
i thought maybe because i wasn't playing
i would take a pay cut and maybe have an
option to stay or
um whatever because of the conversations
we had before but
um to hear that news after after being
with someone like at a club for for so
long that was that was pretty tough and
i was going right well
he's left it quite late as well so i've
not got loads of time to sort something
else out
and a lot of teams over here will do the
recruitment and they'll get it sort of
done by
sort of like christmas time if not
january um
end of january like the latest so i was
thinking right well
it's not left me in the best spot here
and then to make things worse like
four days later i think it was the the
national lockdown because the coffin
kicked in all the games were cancelled
to basically go home we're not going to
train for a month
right i'm in a real pickle here um
so yeah that was real tough i was just
thinking like what is going on like
no teams know when we're starting again
um like when's that going to be like how
much money they're going to lose
so i managed i went back home to my
parents and
done freeze and moved back there i put
all my stuff into
into storage and was just hanging around
and just waiting thinking right well
i hope something comes up but it's not
looking likely for the next couple of
months
because no one knows what's going on um
clubs don't have a clue what's going on
so they're not going to sign anyone
and i was just basically like looking at
my calendar being like right at this
stage i stopped getting paid
like try to save up as much money as i
could
to make sure that i could sort of
outlast whatever whatever was going to
happen
so um yeah that was a pretty tough time
uh to just be waiting around and not
knowing what was going on
um but being back home was good um
my mom and dad were great both my
brothers and all my friends back home
were pretty
really supportive and um yeah it was a
real sort of time that sort of looked at
myself and thought like you've
you've basically took the piss for like
the majority of your career you've not
really knocked down
you've been playing like pretty like
massively overweight
like you've been doing the bare minimum
to to get by and it was only
the realization like oh that that might
be gone now
um i was thinking like what am i gonna
do like even getting a normal job and
this sort of
letting that sort of lock down periods
not going to be easy
so what are you going to do i was
thinking right um
what's one stage like back homes like
like quite a lot of my mates are farmers
and stuff i'm like i'm just gonna have
to text these guys and be like
can i help out the farm just doing
whatever i can um
and that yeah it was pretty scary and
sort of because of that
sort of like self-reflection i just
thought right i'm just gonna smash
training as much as i have like work
real hard i've got all day i've got no
excuse really so
managed to like borrow a few weights
from a local rugby team and
mom and dad got a garden there so just
set up in the garden and then we'd go
down and do
three to four running sessions a week
just like end myself just to
obviously lose weight and then also to
like just
sort of park that thought of not knowing
what's going on in that stress so
just yes like did loads of running so i
ended up i was like playing at like
88 to 90 kilos before and then i ended
up like
getting down to like 79 and was just in
the shape of my life
and was like this is weird like running
around is not not it's not as hard when
you're not a
fat little nine um yeah so i just had
the mindset right
i'll just train for as long as i can
basically
until like financially i've got to make
a decision and
and either work or decide what i want to
do
um but in the meantime if there is a
contract that comes up then
i'll be in i'll be in really good shape
um i'll go in there and
and try and impress and then make sure
that i sort of make the most of it
rather than just sort of
cruising like cruising through my career
like i had done before that
so when you say cruising through like i
always remember you being a real hard
trainer out on the field but
was it your lifestyle choices and what
sort of lifestyle choices was it
other than probably pissing up yeah
personal peeps are definitely one of
them um
sort of not picking in not picking and
choosing the right moment to
let your hair down like i'm not saying
that i've went t total whatsoever
like um still really enjoy socializing
and having a drink and stuff but i was
just
any opportunity there was if that's
we've got training on the tuesday and
off on the wednesday like i've been
texting around everyone at the club of
mates and stuff just
desperate to go out for pints and stuff
like that and
just yeah drink drinking too much but my
lifestyle of not
not like diet was just completely out
the window just takeaways delivered
just just over indulging and everything
like you said like i would train hard on
the pitch and that's the way that would
justify it being like oh well i'll do
that i'll do the work on the pitch and
all that kind of stuff but looking back
now it was just
it was pretty pretty embarrassing
honestly like
to be able to call myself a professional
rugby player with the way that my
lifestyle was
and then also just like did the bare
minimum in the gym and
just sort of do ghost weights just walk
around try to find my water bottle
knowing exactly where it is so i was
missing out on doing weights
and and just that sort of stuff that's
just
not not ideal and at the time i'd always
been in the mix and playing as well so i
thought like
if it's not broken don't fix it sort of
thing at the time i'm just
gonna do what i do and all that kind of
stuff but
looking back now when i started playing
again once i had
eventually signed it harlequins and
stuff like
um rugby just so much easier as a nine
when you're not
blowing blowing all the time and
thinking
a lot of stages when i was playing i was
hoping my own team would drop the ball
so the
scrum sort of slowed down so i get a
rest
another another tactic of of picking and
going like having a snipe when it's not
on because i could sit at the bottom of
the rock and miss out for a few faces
um or just kicking the ball because i
was fed up with our team hovering and i
wanted them of it so i could rest a bit
like
stupid stuff like looking back now and
then
so getting in shape and and losing a bit
of weight and stuff was obviously
massive
um and then just having a new
appreciation of of
what is the to be a professional player
um
and then moving to harlequins which is
as an unreal setup
um in the style of rugby they want to
play is that real fast flowing
uh keep the ball alive keep hold the
ball for long faces and stuff so
they just affected quite well so i went
in there and
they because of the lockdown they had to
condense the games in so we're playing
like on a saturday
wednesday sunday and kept going like
that so i knew that
where i would go if i was going to the
prem that i would end up playing because
they would have to rotate
so i think we had nine games to finish
off that season or something like that
and i ended up playing
seven of them and going well and um
yeah it was just a real good move and i
was grateful for
for them to sort of um sign me because
they sent me as like a
a third choice nine they had two like
pretty
danny care and martin landahl like
really experienced nines there and i was
thinking right well
like ideally moving there is not going
to be great because they're probably
going to
play more than me um and i'm coming in
as a third choice basically
their third choice was an academy lad
that just decided he didn't want to play
anymore and wanted to
stop professional rugby so i was going
in there like took a massive pay cut
just to go there and play but at that
stage it was
i didn't have anything else i was right
i need to sing something so
signing that and and going there and the
way the way it turned out it really
personally for me like performance-wise
we we're a bit inconsistent we play
have a really good win one week and then
drop off the next and then play well the
next week it was up and down but
um for me it was it was really good and
um
sort of good to be being a team that's
obviously trying to
push on and win premierships and stuff
and to be able to contribute in a team
like that it's been
been great so um yeah looking back on
that time it was really
like the toughest time in my life by far
and before that it was pretty plain
sailing but looking back in it now it's
definitely something that
um i appreciate and it's definitely
definitely helped my rugby
since then massively well as soon as you
went to harlequins you're on absolute
fire
and i think what did it only take nine
or so games for them before you get
called in
to the scotland international side yeah
that was that was pretty mental so yeah
we i got called into the
to the autumn stuff and just
like a few years before that i was like
so far away from it like if anything
like i'd sort of
given up on that dream of of playing for
scotland because yeah
i just i've had a few phone calls in the
past but it was always
all you're in contention but you've
missed out and then
then phone calls like stopped happening
for the last two years before that and i
was just thinking right well that's
that's probably
done um i was 27
i'm not saying it's really old but at
that stage i thought if i was going to
play i probably have played by now
um to get called into that after you say
like
seven games or whatever it was uh
was unreal and a bit of a surreal moment
for me um
and it was great and it was just one of
them that was it was
it was more sort of to do with what it
meant to like my family and stuff like
that because what they'd seen me go
through
um it was a big moment to get called
into that that squad and
i only ended up playing in in one game
but to even be sort of named in
in that squad sort of shoot showed like
weird
weird came like how far it came in that
last couple of months so
um that was amazing unreal experience
and just basically started to get that
um sort of recognition for for the the
work that i put in and how i was playing
at quinn's
and was was amazing and unreal yeah
and how did the debut uh debbie was
interesting so
obviously it was covered so um we played
wales
um down in part scarlett
it wasn't at the millennium because that
was set up as a covert center
so i was like right i've played at
scott's before no offense it's not the
nicest place in the world to play
but um beggars can't be choosers and
after the last like
six months i've had i was thinking right
doesn't matter where it is
so it's a pretty tight game and uh i
think we were we were leading with like
maybe like 50 minutes to go or something
like that and we had a lot of injuries
our 10 went off with
uh just to get children a few other guys
got injured and
i got on and i was on the wing and and i
was breaking
i was breaking it because um i was
thinking right if i came on at nine it's
pretty like standard you know what to do
all that kind of stuff but i was like
if i miss one tackle here and they score
that's a game done and like
scotland hunt beat wales in wales for
like 18 years and they've been
all this hype about how we're going to
be the team that does it
and i was thinking i'm not a winger like
what if they just put a high ball up in
me and like
josh adams or one of these unreal
wingers just comes and
plucks it out there i was like right so
i was pretty nervous like
um but i got through it made a couple of
tackles hit a few rocks and
and we won so that was amazing um
and then i was thinking oh it's not
ideal like no one's at a watch mom and
dad couldn't be there to watch but
um to be fair like the the sort of the
staff at scotland they set up like a
zoom
so they could see my like my cat
presentation and all that kind of stuff
in the changing room and i could speak
to them and
speak to them after and it was it was
class that all my mates were loving it
um yeah but that that was a meal was a
bit strange obviously with everything
that was going on and being on the wing
but
um to get that cap was was unreal and
like a real special moment yeah
oh how good is that and then obviously
the big six nations you
ended up having about four or five caps
in that tournament didn't you and
scotland had a really good tournament
yeah so i went into that um so obviously
i went back to quinn's and played with
them and then then got called in six
nations squad and
there was only two nines and picked in
the squad so i was thinking oh this is
this is great
um hopefully hopefully going to play and
ended up playing um
yeah playing i think it was like three
uh three games in that and
didn't go on against wales we had a few
we had a red card and a few injuries and
then didn't play
in the last game against france but um
the game against england was unreal like
we hadn't beat england
at twickenham for like 38 years um
so to come on come off the bench there
for the last 15 minutes or so and
and play well and and and to get that
win put on an excellent clinic
oh yeah just box kicks that was the
championship here that got me
got me through that just kicking
everything it was pissing down the rain
and i just thought
this suits me
so yeah played played well in that and
to win there was unreal
but um yeah it was quite quite surreal
moment because
a few years before there was a crazy
game it was like ferry all
scotland england at twickenham and i was
sitting in like the the stands with a
few mates and stuff like that
um on an all-day session drinking pints
and watching a few guys that i'd played
20s with and stuff like that i'd really
kicked on and played well and i just
thought like
that's that's past me like if i have not
really fulfilled the potential here
whatsoever i was like
starting over through these guys and was
like playing in these teams and they've
like went on to do
do like amazing things and i'm just sort
of plodding along doing my thing and
then
a couple of years fast forward and then
i'm playing in that game that we beat
them and stuff like that so that was
that was a crazy moment sort of sit back
and be like you've done all right there
to be fair um yeah
so yeah that was great and that was yeah
i was probably
i'll say that was that was even better
than my debut just
to go down there and actually properly
play my part in a win
um such a historic win and so so many
messages after that game
it was unreal people that had helped me
in my career
since day one and all that kind of stuff
that that was amazing um
and then to play um
against ireland in the back row that was
an experience that
you mentioned i didn't didn't like that
as much because we didn't win but it was
also a dream come true to play in the
back row with the style of play that i
liked
to adopt so um that was interesting as
well
but um and then obviously made made my
first start against italy
um and we won that game it looked a bit
like a bit nervous at the start they
scored first and i was going on nah like
you can't get your first start against
italy
at home and lose or whatever like that
would be the end of me that the career
international career has done but we
turned it around we played well we
ended up beating them pretty comfortably
and then ended up scoring a try as well
which was which was nice
um you know one of the great yeah my
range is
from five meters out and below so it was
just a classic
you know pick and go and any further out
than that
i need to look to pass it so um no it
was it was a good day in the school that
was
it was the icing on the cake but yeah
overall loved the whole experience like
as a team
uh we were disappointed with how it
ended up like we always had a good few
results but the games that we lost it
was
real tight margins and we sort of let
them slip so
um it was just amazing to be involved in
a team with
so many world-class players like says
stuart hogg and
finn russell and hamish watson and guys
like that like
eight or so of them all the prices come
off all these guys went on to to get
picked for the lions which is amazing to
see
um and wasn't surprised any of them to
be honest
the way like training with them and
playing with them uh you get a real
appreciation
of how hard these guys work and and how
good they are um
but also just all really good blokes as
well which helps so it's amazing to see
see them kick on and hopefully uh do
real well in the summer
did you get a message from ron gatlin or
anything about your line selection
versatility
no i just missed out yeah i just missed
out
but i'm thinking i'll probably be on the
reserve list just to utility sort of
cover any positions so
uh i'll
hopefully he'll watch the podcast and he
can
see that message and know that i'm
available if needed
yeah he is a big fan of the podcast i'm
sure oh no dave
who isn't who isn't
but anyway we had a moment there when
you had no rugby so did you ever think
about
what's next had you thought much about
it before that or during that time were
you like [ __ ]
what am i going to do after rugby um
that time yeah that time was i was
a bit like oh no what am i gonna do um
yeah more circumstantial of like the
whole
like um locked down and uh
like it was it wasn't easy to sort of go
into anything like
i've always sort of thought maybe i'll
stay involved in rugby somehow
uh whether that's coaching or i've even
looked at refereeing
um but even then it was like right well
none of that's going on anyway so i
can't really
i can't go down coaching the locals
because no one's doing anything so
the whole sporting world just stopped so
that was that was scary but like i said
yeah
like looking at coaching um looking to
get involved in
some coaching down here in london um
helping
out the odd session at wimbledon and
just going down doing the old session a
week
and then um looking to actually get
involved and
doing some scrum half coaching with the
harlequins
women's team um they're a pretty decent
team over here they just they just won
the league and
um looking to to help out with them and
sort of do some individual coaching
um scrum half stuff which i'd say would
be more what i'd look to
to be involved in um and then
also looking to to study more sports
psychology stuff
something that i'm interested in um
just more more to do like being through
the
sort of things that i've been through in
my career i think it'd be a good option
for me to do and
particularly help out young guys coming
into sort of full-time rugby i think
um they sort of just get left to figure
out some harsh realities and
some guys come in thinking that they're
going to play every game and
the next best thing and they don't
realize that guys have been doing it for
years and
it takes more than a few good training
sessions to to
more a selection in the team and how you
deal with that and then on the flip side
guys coming in thinking that they're not
good enough and
they're in the wrong environment and
they shouldn't be here so um yeah
yeah that's something that i'm i'm
looking to do but if i'm honest
since uh that's sort of that scare of
not knowing what i was going to do it's
definitely
sort of popped up my motivation to to
look into
stuff after rugby because um i don't
want to be in that sort of spot again
where i have
no clue what i'm going to do so um send
an extension at quinn's for
the next two seasons so really need to
knuckle down and and get
get sort of cracking on with that um
while i've got the opportunity
oh how good is that you'll be a gun at
either of those especially sports site
because man you have been through
you've been through it all seen it all
you can share on something yeah
very good lessons yeah learn from your
mistakes
yeah do as i say not as i did
you're one of them exactly
oh mate what a journey what a career but
before we get
move on we've got to go to our instagram
for some questions
and mate you you've come up with plenty
a bit nervous jim
fair enough no
they're not too bad uh first question
haggis thoughts i really enjoy haggis
it's really good especially if you get
it from a chip shop
and it's covered in batter yeah i really
really do enjoy that and don't have it
every day like some people say when they
ask are you scottish do you hug it all
the time no
no not at all but when i go home from
the chip shop
i'll definitely enjoy having a bit of
haggis yeah deep fry cheese i don't know
it was deep-fried
that's the way to have it is it yeah
exactly yeah
excellent okay two words to describe
your gentleman area
i know the answer that he wants me to
give which is
is tiny and it stinks um
because that was a a long-running joke
that i've
said to a girl on a night out and for
some reason she was fascinated with it i
wouldn't leave me alone after i said it
and so that's a that's a running joke
that um we have
um but no it's just tiny it doesn't
stink
classic okay what is your biggest
attribute on your body blair cowan
what a lab that should be on my body
oh i know what he's getting at there um
uh well i don't know it freeze it but
if what i said before was tiny
um the other things down there are both
massive
that's all i'm saying
i always say that girls don't care about
how big your piece is
it's all about the balls so
i don't know how true it is but it helps
me sleep at night so
yeah it's true now
it's true
okay what player did you look up to
growing up
um that's a scottish from off i looked
up to
chris cassette um he played scotland
played
clean lines to us and stuff like that
was real exciting to watch we were
running for
real sort of um abrasive nine love
getting stuck in
um kelleher as well
kiwi massive bloke just loved getting
stuck in
um but yeah i'd say i'd say them two
guys were sort of what i
looked up to but well also sort of
thought right i'm
a little bit similar to them in the way
that i like the physical side of the
game
um and also love defending which isn't
really rare for a nine um but yeah then
them two guys were sort of
guys that also sort of looked like they
they enjoyed that part of the game so
yeah them too
like that okay next one back row back
line number nine what position is next
for the steel man
um good question
i reckon if i go off the rails again and
put on a few pounds then i could
probably do a job at hooker as well
saw my darts out put on a bit of weight
later on in my career drop down the
leagues have a stint in the front row
why not back on the uber eats
as well by saying i need to put on
weight if i want to play in the front
row i'm doing the right thing
okay ask him about the time he fell in
the field on his way home
from a night out in richmond is that
from gilly
this is from connor yeah well
um we lived together at the time and um
i'd had a night out and it was i think
it was like
jeb's leaving drinks or whatever um so
it was a big one and we're in richmond
and then a few of the guys we
went up to get some food and they were
they were kicking on into into clapham
and infernos the the usual spot to
end the night out but for some reason i
was trying to be sensible and said now
i'm going home
i've had enough so i've got uh uh
went to byron berg i got a big burger
whatever and i was walking home back
across richmond bridge
and i got caught short and i was like i
really need to take a [ __ ]
so i was thinking right just get your
head down get home
it's probably about 15 minute walk but i
get like halfway there and i was like oh
no i need to i need to go here
so it was a wet night and i've just put
my food down to the side and
sort of right i'm gonna have to do it
like squat it down
took my jocks down did what i needed to
do
and as i get up i remember putting my
hand on this car next to me
and it was a ford 4k i'll never forget
it
and i've did that so i've like pulled
everything up
uh used like napkins and stuff out of my
delivery bag to wipe off and just chuck
away
and i've pulled it back up and then i've
went to push off this car at the side of
it like that and it's just
slipped and i've just fell and
like and sat right in
my [ __ ] that i've just done and i could
just feel the warmth
coming through my jeans onto my arse i
was going like
oh my god so i've had my
put my jeans on tried to wipe it off i
was like walking home and it was
obviously steaming so i get back to the
flat and gilly's there and he's in the
living room just chilling
and he's like you're right and i was
like yeah good mate good mate i'm just
got delivered i'm just gonna head
upstairs like what's that on on your
jeans and stuff and i was like
it's nothing me it's nothing real
schedule it's nothing get away from me
all right chill out like what is it like
you don't murder that i was like
yeah mate i was coming back i took a
shortcut and jumped a fence and fell
over in the field he was like
we're in the middle of richmond there's
no fields
next morning like see these jeans like
chuck them out and he was like
what happened last night you said like
you're steaming through a field
yeah actually just took a [ __ ] and then
sat on it so that's the most
oh my god
oh i really like that pair of jeans as
well so i was guided but
they had to go but
okay next one
uh talk about when the sky remote went
missing from your room
oh classic um
we were on an ao i had a few drinks and
then
when i had an after party back at us
this is when me and gilly were living
together as well
um and i managed to charm
a nice young lady back into my room and
uh what happened happened whatever and
then
she was she was yeah she was an
interesting girl but um
she left and in the morning whatever
i've woke up and i've went to turn my tv
on like hanging out my ass just want to
put the tv on chill out with and i'm
looking there going like
where the [ __ ] is my remote whatever for
ages like
cleared out my whole room whatever
looked up as i
she's [ __ ] stole my tv remote last
night what is she up to
so then i was like speaking of gilly who
was like his girlfriend knew this girl
and uh i was like this is a bit of a
weird one but can you ask her
if she stole my tv remote last night so
like she's asked her that question she's
like no why would i do that
like this guy's a weirdo all this kind
of stuff going on for ages
and then i've moved out the flat and i'm
still not found that tv
remote so i think she's lying but to
this day that mystery is still not being
sold without the tv
so we had a secret santa trick last
year yeah no we had a secret santa last
year
um and what i got for secret santa was
it
was a sky tv remote to replace the one
that had been stolen
so that's that's still a mystery still
no idea what happened to that
geez good stuff gilly's coming up
trump's with a couple of questions
okay last question this one could be one
of the greatest answers ever on the
podcast what you've been through but
one piece of advice for a young kid
coming through who wants to play
freshman rugby
um if they want to properly play
professionally um
it would be to to make sure that you
never
take it for granted um there's a lot of
people out there that would
give an arm and a leg to to play one
professional game rugby for
for not just their club but for any club
and to be able to say that they've done
that
so um yeah for me it would just be to
to enjoy every moment but to make the
most of it to not look back and
and say oh if only i'd done that if only
i'd taken a bit more seriously etc
um that that would be my advice because
you sort of get caught up thinking that
it's a tough
tough life you know we do all this
trading we play this brutal game and we
get bashed around but
at the end of the day so it's an
unbelievable lifestyle and it's a great
opportunity to do it so
um make the most of it while you can
because on the other side of things
um you don't know how long it's going to
last even if you you do do all the work
with injuries and stuff so
really just make the most of it and make
sure you can look back and say
well i did everything i could oh mate i
put the pressure on and you delivered
that is the best piece of advice
you did put the pressure on big time oh
you've delivered
you always deliver when the pressure's
on the fear the fear gets you home
yeah the fear gets you through you'll
always get shifted that's another bit of
advice
oh anyway sterling absolute pleasure
having on the podcast jeez that was a
good yarn and what a story it's been
awesome to see you turn your career
around like you said you're in a you're
in a tough place for a while there but
to see you on the biggest stage now
playing for scotland playing for your
country is just so cool to see
i've loved watching your journey love
playing with you while i was at london
norris you're an absolute lad and
um yeah thanks for coming on the podcast
and sharing some absolute yarns
cheers mate really appreciate it um no
great great to catch up and loving the
podcast
i'm a keen fan listen to a lot of them
especially the guys that i know
uh keep up the great work um ensure to
get
get more lads on that i know over this
side of the of the world so i can
tune in yeah matt you're a lad cheers
man
all the best
[Music]
what